let's but let's talk about you know I we
always do it the the double standards
and the hypocrisy of our good Democrat
voter and activist friends take a look
at this story from timcast.com Ukraine
says they have supplied 18 000 weapons
to Citizens anti-gun leftists celebrate
their efforts my favorite is occupy
Democrats let me let me pull up this
image from defiant elves occupy
Democrats first tweeted no civilian
needs an AR-15 regardless of whatever
whatever meant mental gymnastics you do
you are a very special breed of stupid
and they then you know about six years
later breaking Ukraine's interior
Minister announces that 10 000 automatic
rifles have been handed out to the
civilians of kieval as they prepare to
fight tooth and nail to defend their
homes against Putin's Invasion RT if you
stand with the brave people of Ukraine
now hold on hold on hold on everybody
I think occupy Democrats are right I
think Joe Biden's correct you know what
I was wrong to criticize The
Establishment when they said Putin was a
very real threat I stand corrected you
guys you're right I think our government
should join in as well and give all of
the United States citizens some
automatic weapons yes so because
Vladimir Putin's such a big threat to
yeah yeah right I'm terrified and and
China you know oh but but Putin so um
I'll take a I'll take a fully a
selectifier yeah yeah yeah something
while you're handing them out
regarding this guy's first tweet he's
talking to the the air and then he says
you're stupid this is something I think
people should avoid this is a little odd
topic when you're when you're using
social media and you're like complaining
towards someone and you they start
insulting them if you do it on social
media a lot of people that are
unintendedly reading it are gonna feel
like you're insulting them yeah so don't
do that you are a very special breed of
stupid yeah who are you talking to me no
they're talking to themselves apparently
because now they're tweeting that he's
they and they actually really say
civilians like no civilians in AR-15 to
be fair they're handing out Collision
costs oh yeah okay
keep in mind here they think they still
think AR stands for automatic rifle yes
so what's what's crazy is they don't
think any civilian needs a
semi-automatic rifle but they are
thrilled about fully automatic AKs going
out that's actually a really good point
maybe maybe we're being mean to our good
friends no civilian needs an AR-15 what
they're really saying is it's semi-auto
yeah correct
and if one of those selects is not full
auto then occupied Democrats it's not
satisfied that's right there you go 50
BMG
so so maybe what they're really saying
is that um no no civilian needs a a a
semi-auto single shot come on yeah need
full auto that's right only the best
that's what they're getting at the whole
time
let's talk about the asymmetrical
Warfare though because um I mean this is
the reality
when when when you try to invade someone
else that the big challenge for Vladimir
Putin is going to be
demoralized Russian soldiers a funded
amount of them versus the entirety of of
Ukraine civilians who have remained who
are going to be like I'm gonna fight you
it's actually surprising there's there's
a number I I think a lot of people and I
think Putin thought this would be
something where hey as soon as the
armored divisions go rolling across the
border you know presidents leaving the
country you know uh nope you put on body
armor yeah I mean you're gonna you gotta
hand it to him like okay took out a gun
right I don't know if I believe it it's
propaganda but it's good propaganda yeah
if you're trying to Rally I mean let's
face it if especially when you're
engaging in asymmetrical Warfare you are
the weaker party
propaganda is one of the key things
you're going we still got Democrats that
think that we lost the Ted offensive
right why because Walter Cronkite said
we lost the Ted offensive Oh I thought
we lost the Tet Offensive yeah didn't
people just get rolled over North
Vietnam and all all down Vietnam didn't
the the Americans get annihilated no no
what happened yeah are you serious on
the Ted offensive what happened yeah oh
oh okay well real quick Segway yeah yeah
so okay
so so yeah in Vietnam the Viet Cong
launched a massive attack all throughout
the country during tet which was
supposed to be a ceasefire within the
the Vietnamese calendar right and so
they they made like some
fairly
major gains quickly but with like in
several weeks they had taken massive
amounts of calories we're like talking
like 20 to 1 at that point it was after
the Ted offense said that the North
Vietnamese actual North Vietnamese Army
had to start coming in and supporting
because we had almost wiped out the Viet
Cong after the Ted offense they threw
they threw the kitchen sink at it and
they got obliterated so it looked bad
overnight partly because our own
military you know leaders were saying oh
yes they're on their heels they can't do
anything well they launched this major
offensive it was unexpected they got
temporary gains but they got destroyed
but it didn't matter the the propaganda
campaign that went along with it made it
look like one the military or the the
government was lying to the people which
is certainly not hard to believe and
then the other two was that this never
would have happened if we were actually
in the good shape that we were and as
Thomas likes to say when a democracy
decides you've lost the war you've lost
it and so that was the problem but again
if you look at something like this the
propaganda component for an asymmetric
force is critical Psych ecology is one
of the most important things in a war
yeah so why we're seeing so much
propaganda because making people feel
like we can win we should win and we
have to win is important to keeping
people in the fight so there's a video
of poroshenko you know throwing a a
strap over he's got he's got a rifle of
some sort and he's like I'm here on the
ground and he's like here's all the you
know other people I'm fighting with
you've got president zielinski and he's
like I'm with the Prime Minister I'm
with the cabinet from this guy we're
here on the ground he's got like a vest
on
because the people of Ukraine they're
going to see that and they're being
handed out guns yeah and they're and
when you see your leader on the
battlefield with you they're going to be
like it's um like my favorite movie The
Patriot with Mel Gibson good movie when
he says hold the line and he runs back
yeah when they're retreating and then
they they pull forward and win that's
the thing but let me tell you what you
know you mentioned we got into Vietnam I
gotta I gotta tell you the story I read
it's fascinating
so uh the U.S was trying to engage in
psychological warfare something I read
on the internet perhaps not true
and so what they did was they knew that
the Vietnamese were very superstitious
so they made these these creepy
recordings of wailing haunting
Vietnamese like Viet Cong soldiers
saying you know uh why did I fight I
should have gone home they believe they
believe uh that if you are not given a
proper burial you're forced to haunt
wherever it was you died so in in the
the you know the forestry the jungle or
whatever they're playing in these
loudspeakers wailing Vietcong voices
saying flee while you still can or
you'll be trapped like me it was so
effective the South Vietnamese flight as
well and so they had to stop doing it oh
that's just I don't know if it's true it
sounds amazing it's one of those stories
you hear you know it's probably
apocryphal or something yeah it's one of
those if it's not true it ought to be
right right right right I mean it's kind
of messed up though you know going after
people's like it's like a psychic attack
on superstitious cultures tend to get
wiped out I think are there any that
exist anymore I don't think so there's a
lot of superstitious cultures like like
the Christian Cal Berkeley no there's
Christian and Islam which are both kind
of Superstar there's tons of like
Americans have tons of superstitions but
like it's easy to manipulate someone to
pursue go to a casino and you will see
years ago or a sporting event yeah
you'll see you'll see a guy like tap his
Coke can five times yeah well that
concerns me because superstitious people
are easy to manipulate well it's like
it's like Michael Scott says I'm not
superstitious but I am a little stitched
yeah yeah man so so uh let it be known
they're giving out all these guns to
regular people because it works yeah I
want to see Biden hitting a speed bag I
need some motivation get on the floor
bro yeah let's go oh that's a funny
thing awesome speed I'll tell you what
what'll be interesting on this though is
that and this is the part where okay
again how does Ukraine stall Russia how
does Ukraine like capture the press and
the media and the propaganda and all of
this and and this is going to be
interesting because the first war we've
seen like this where literally everybody
has got access to the world to some
degree from their phone yeah so you
imagine uh partisans out there doing
this sort of stuff and then making a
tick tock about it right that that's
going to be that's going to be a
fascinating thing to potentially watch
from not just from a propaganda
perspective but as sharing information
perspective because if you don't think
terrorist organizations already use
social media in order to coordinate
their activities
um that there's regardless of what ends
up happening here there's going to be a
lot of research and study going into how
social media influenced it from a
propaganda from a coordination
standpoint uh because there's there's
good ways for partisans to fight and
there's really stupid ways for partisans
to fight and partisans should not be
taking on a T90 with their AK-47 right
this is it's it's just crazy I I I'm
trying to figure out why Putin would do
this
I I and the only thing I come up with is
it's it's the last great hurray of a
Dying Empire
they're not part of NATO if I play
Crusader Kings too you know I play a lot
of like battle Conquest Grand simulation
strategy games and if you have a lot of
countries with a defensive pact against
you but one of them isn't in The Pact
that's the country you hit and you take
it fast and then you're done and then no
one complains anymore it's just back to
base zero again and hopefully no one
else signs up for The Pact and if
someone drops out of the pack their
hunger they're a meaty Target oh he's
got a he's got a war weary United States
which is the only one that has any teeth
he's got a Europe that's been you know
hit by covet and doesn't want to deal
with this crap and everyone everyone on
the western side can say Ukraine wasn't
a part of NATO now if you do it to
Poland we'll be pissed excuse me if you
do it to Estonia right we'll we'll be
pulling yeah yeah Estonia Latvia
Lithuania we get out of NATO
yeah what do you think because
we've had those conversations here yeah
all the weight we do we do pull all the
weight it's going to be interesting to
see what happens because well NATO
hasn't been attacked right so it'd be
interesting to see well not that I'm
wishing for this
um I do think that there's something to
be said and this is a part and this is
the part where I'm I'll probably get a
little bit amped up
um
because again I've lost friends overseas
fighting Wars that you know I'm not so
sure where where the best decision on
America's part
um but one of the things that has has
maintained the level of peace that we've
seen since World War II and obviously
there's been horrible conflict conflicts
in Vietnam in Korea and other places
that we've been involved in that we
haven't been involved in but nothing
like the massive Bloodshed we saw in
World War one and World War II
and the reason why we have that and the
reason why for the last 30 years we
haven't even imagined a conflict like
this the reason why this is surprisingly
living piss out of everybody is because
of U.S military dominance that's why the
same thing that a lot of our allies are
constantly bitching about
and and coming to the United States and
talking about oh you know they're always
throwing their weight around they're
always going yeah and and because we
have and because people know we can
it has kept people at Bay and no one's
going to convince me otherwise it really
has yeah and so now we're at a point
where you do you have a war weary United
States you have a global pandemic that
took place we have a country that we
have no legal obligation to defend and I
think that the the kind of the world
order
post-cold war is being challenged right
now by Putin
and he's probably picked the best
possible time to do it
and and again that's why I said that the
same countries that will want the United
States to intervene to do the heavy
lifting for them if we decide to do it
we'll be bitching about us six months
from now
and so I don't think we should
now does that mean do we we pull out of
things like NATO I think there's I think
there's value
with the United States being the
preeminent military power
and I I think that does do something to
preventing other nations from getting a
little bit froggy when they shouldn't
um but one of the things again that I
appreciated about how Trump handled this
was he went back to Nato and he made it
very real possibility that you might not
be able to rely on us because you're not
pulling your weight and and that's not
the same for allies that we have in like
South Korea or Taiwan they do pull their
weight they do recognize the threat they
do recognize their responsibility to
hold back the threat and yes they depend
on the United States for support but
they don't they don't have this
expectation that they don't got to do
the fighting because we got this
and so I think
one of the positive things that could
come out of this is a lot of these
countries that it's become real popular
to trash the United States
um are going to realize that you know
what what do you think your country
would look like Western Europe if it was
Putin that had the military and economic
power that the United States had you
think we'd be having these conversations
nope you think we'd be talking about
eastern Ukraine or you think we'd be
talking about the south of France right
now so just remember as much as the
United States may screw up on our
foreign policy as much as we might
at a time where we had all the power all
the money all the military might show me
the country that we annexed into the
United States
in order to expand our own Empire well
Iraq but we didn't
we don't we don't own Iraq not on paper
no no not not at all I mean again the
way that you look at you look at Russia
if Russia takes over Ukraine watch what
happens in Ukraine it's going to be
nothing like what happened yeah I was
really impressed with the
Spanish-American War what I've read
about it is that the Americans basically
liberated Cuba for better or worse they
didn't invade and take it they get
they'd kicked the Spanish Empire out and
we're like now cube is free yeah I mean
we didn't do that in the Philippines but
we didn't do that in the Philippines
this is not me suggesting that the
United States military has not had our
own little brush with Empire we've done
things that we shouldn't have done I
mean go look at what Lincoln was saying
about the Mexican-American War go look
at what Grant was saying about the
Mexican-American War about how we we
kind of picked a fight with the country
we knew we could kick the crap out of
and then got a lot of territory from it
so like again I'm not saying we're we're
perfect but if you look at the the
situation in the world it has been the
the level of peace and security that has
existed in certain parts of the world
especially in Western Europe has been
and as a direct result of U.S military
it's the Kissinger limited War Doctrine
he was a big part of creating this idea
that we're going to create we're going
to fight proxy wars only so that we
don't go to Total War I I mean I'm not a
huge Kissinger fan me neither but um but
that was his yeah I'm not a huge
Kissinger fan and I'm I think it's I
don't like to call it the proxy war idea
that like okay if we just get involved
in a bunch of little Wars we'll stop big
ones I do think there's an argument to
say that there is such a thing as the
sudeten land moment
right where there was a point where the
French military the the British military
if they had intervened in Sudan land or
if they'd intervene when you know the
Nazis were going into Czechoslovakia and
just carving it up because they could
would with that whole scene turned out a
lot differently than if they waited all
the way till Poland and and I I think
there's an argument to be made there I I
think there's an argument to be made
that you you identify when someone has
larger aspirations when they have the
military capability to do it and you
intervene at a point where they realize
that okay we're not going to get away
with this you don't let them build up a
certain significant amount of power to
where they now can potentially get away
with that's kind of we've been doing in
Iran well like I've heard the stuxnet we
blew up infrastructure I think have they
targeted them with weapons blow up
weapons Depots and stuff I don't know
how hot it's gotten the stuck the
stuxnet was obviously you know fairly
significant and they've also tried to
manage their growth through
um sanctions and so we could have done
that to Germany looking back in
retrospect we could have tried to to
somehow disrupt their rise to power but
it was internal it was like how could we
get involved and stop the military
machine from creating itself no I think
it's more of and again I'm I'm I am very
I tend to I always side with
non-interventionists and then you need
to explain why something is so
significant the United States men and
women need to bleed for it right that's
my starting point now when you're
talking about something like Germany
again when you have internal issues I I
tend to say look you stay out of those
those are internal issues piece of
westophilia right but once you start
seeing naked aggression like you did
with the Sudan land with Germany or like
you did with Czechoslovakia then I think
there is some argument to say like okay
is it is it appropriate at this point to
intervene on some level now now what
there's a big difference there's there's
a you know there's uh I'm trying to
think of the word now um there's levels
of force that you apply right there's an
escalation of force not everything has
to be like you went into the sedan land
I'm nuking Berlin right and it's not
that but it sounds like Trump yeah right
but that's the thing it's there's a
difference between okay what's going to
be your escalation of force right that's
what you know that's not what you share
with the rest of the world you want you
want Putin thinking you you send one
Russian troop into Ukraine right and I'm
going into Moscow right it's going to be
I'm gonna up a Trump Hotel in downtown
right because he doesn't know if you're
actually going to do it and so that's
where there's a difference between okay
what should be our actual strategy
versus what sort of strategy should we
project right and our enemies don't get
to know this one they just get to know
what we're capable of Biden said
recently you know the minor
encouragement it depends on if it's a
minor incursion that was a piece that
was Pro preemptive appeasement should
have said outright we'll go into Moscow
Biden's the Netherlands or I mean and
worse possibly the Buchanan yeah but he
could have said we won't tolerate this
Europe won't tolerate this Ukraine
Poland the Baltic states Western Europe
none of it if Putin makes this move we
go into Moscow day one try me
the thing is here's what I'll say though
if Biden had said that he would have
show a hands on who believes
he's like I don't buy that he would have
been reading a prompter and he would go
come on man we go we're going to Moscow
look here forget it Corn Pop
go to Moscow Vladimir Putin's a bad dude
who's got some bad boys someone called
Putin a bad dude yesterday
I think he was going to say bad mother
in uh in the video you can hear him
start to say the word mother and he
stops himself and says dude instead yeah
dude Biden yeah when you lose that dude
real weird bad dude yeah dude this is
like when when Hitler went into Poland
to like reconquer part of poem that had
been Stripped Away after the first world
war and give it back because apparently
he said there was a genocide of German
expats in Poland that they were
committing
um Putin says the same thing there's a
genocide of Russians in eastern Ukraine
that's been going on for eight years
I've heard an inkling of this in the
media I don't know if it's real or
complete propaganda but this was
Hitler's reason for invading Poland or
part of it probably also to connect you
know more land bridges and stuff because
he had Hitler was like ready to take
over the world there's there's a
conflict in in the donbass region and
you've got people saying yeah the
separatists are dying you get people
saying ukrainians are dying and both
sides will use what they can to justify
their positions yeah I don't know who's
more right or more morally right I don't
know I I know that both sides are making
those assertions I think that I think
Putin is doing what he wanted to do and
then he found reasons to do it so should
we I guess my question in is should we
treat this like how we treated Hitler
invading Poland where it's a different
time and I'll pray that I don't I don't
either because America took Iraq 20
years ago and that that was gave the
Russians uh no opportunity to match the
playing field uq can't look two wrongs
don't make a right the U.S screwed up
with Iraq and Afghanistan they're
screwing up today by still being
absolutely it's not like it happened
it's happening right now unscript
miserably leaving Afghanistan yeah but
we can't be like well Russia gets to
take a sovereign country because the
United States did it too that's that's
what and and even then the thing that I
go back to is that with Iraq and
Afghanistan there was there was no point
where Iraq became the 51st state or or
Afghanistan became a territory now again
I I don't I think there was huge
problems with the way we did a lot of it
now I don't think it was wrong to go
after the Taliban I don't think it was
wrong to go after terrorism I don't
think any of that was wrong I think
there was something significantly wrong
with this idea that we're going to come
in here completely devastate whatever
current government is in charge and then
we're going to go ahead and recreate you
on our image but I think it was Ron Paul
who said that when it came to the
Taliban after 9 and we should have
issued letters of Mark and reprisal
specifically targeting the group not the
country not going after television would
have cannibalized each other it would
have been awesome instead it was like
let's Nation build for 20 years oh no if
you if you look at the initial Invasion
so again in the military I was Army
Special Forces it's better known as
Green Berets Green Berets focus on
unconventional War for counter
uncertainty what does that mean it means
when we go into a country we work by
through and with local allies the
indigenous population you look at the
opening days of Afghanistan we're
talking about you had agency in there
you had you know I
several hundred Green Berets working
with the Northern Alliance and within
what a couple of months like they had
kicked the Taliban out of like Kandahar
and it was all buy through with the
local population and what would have
been fascinating to watch and and who
knows what would have happened would it
fascinated watches what sort of organic
solutions people would have come up to
and I'm sure it would have been you know
ugly and I'm sure it would have been
brutal at times everything else but
it wouldn't have been the United States
saying no no we're not just going to
fight the towel we're going to take over
the entire country we're going to take
over the entire Awards now our war we're
going to help you with your
infrastructure we're going to help
because some of this I don't know if
you've ever seen read the book or seen
the movie Charlie Wilson's War a big
argument that they made is that we went
in there to help the mujahideen against
the Soviets and then we didn't stand by
stay behind in order to help with some
of the infrastructure and so it got out
of hand and so this time as well we're
not going to repeat that mistake we'll
just double down and take over the whole
damn thing okay no you're trying to
impose certain cultural political social
changes on a culture that is not
necessarily interested in the social
changes that you're trying to affect it
doesn't matter whether or not you think
it's more moral than what they currently
have if you don't have buy-in there then
don't expect to be able to do it unless
you're willing to stay there for a
hundred years that's my concern with
Iraq they say it's not a state but
what's the plan either we're going to be
there for 100 years yeah we have no
significant military right yeah it's
drawn down actually I I just don't
believe that I don't know where that
comes that idea comes from but it's like
locked down by the United States or
whoever's there is it American weapons
in the Iraqi puppets hands like it's a
large nation that has well been well
defended by the United States for two
decades oh we've been we have not been a
significant military force on the ground
in Iraq for
gosh dang we're probably I mean
trying to think of the actual I was last
over there in 08 I think by 2013 we were
really drawing down significantly
um so no I mean we have not had a
significant military presence in Iraq
for I mean it's getting close to you
yeah I think under Obama he he pulled
all troops out of Iraq put him into
Afghanistan he moved a lot down there
then he reinforced in Afghanistan and by
the Trump by the time Trump was in there
I mean we have a huge embassy over there
there was some military presence but
that was one of the big complaints right
is that the reason why isil was able to
come in and do so much was because we
didn't have a significant U.S military
presence it seems like Iraq is a staging
ground and so is Afghanistan for like
Russian and interference Iranian yeah
Iranian they've got Syria On the Border
they're close to Egypt in the South they
gotta their eyes poking into Saudi
Arabia's North border well that's been I
mean Saudi Arabia was when the during
the Cold War Iraq uh especially Syria
and all that that was very clearly
Soviet sphere of influence Iraq was a
little bit because they were they were
taking most of the military equipment
Egypt was Soviet influence at a certain
point and then Saudi Arabia was more U.S
influence
um so it's just been an interesting
Dynamic but keep in mind all those
borders were you know drawn by British
map makers so thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast to IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there